ronnie's going to start out by cleaning
the computer we just accumulate so much
stuff and ronnie's been sitting on this
for a while he's got a report on the
adult video news
awards go ahead ron it's like you know
it's the oscar they're oscars
you know right uh the show started with
uh
in in memoriam in memoriam's segment
you're saying great the people who died
right well that well yeah it started
with an in memoriam segment
right it's a way it was way more
entertaining than the in
in mormorium at the oscars in in morium
and
maurium yeah when they're trying to
remember the dead people in [ __ ]
yeah that's what i said in memorial yeah
ronnie you sound like you're reading
this for the first time yeah howard can
i yell at him for one second like
the whole idea of this is we have these
old packages
we asked the guys if they want to you
know deliver one of these packages
because they have a passion about it
they like the content
like it's like he's reading it for the
first [ __ ] time like what are you
doing
he could listen to this before like this
is supposed to be a whole thing did you
rehearse him you can't say in memoriam
dude
listen [ __ ] yourself okay this is what
you get when you get me
ronnie has the delivery of the
terminator i i i'm not a [ __ ] uh uh
announcer yeah we know you get me
okay sounds like a third grade book
report
yeah okay fine no ronnie what you should
have done is
you read it over i read it over 100
[ __ ] times
what did you do to prepare ronnie just
get up yeah i got up and i took a shower
and i came in here this morning i came
in and uh you know i had to
i looked over the stuff and that's it
well you're not satisfied with what he
did
i believe it's fine you get what you get
from ronnie it's all it's all a plus
it's all bonuses well i said it was a
compliment
it's funny when you can't read it's
great
[Laughter]
you're real nice i feel like uh will
shattered ronnie's confidence he didn't
sound good
so he took all the wind out of his sails
gary she said with that big [ __ ] grin
on his face that's all he does
i'm not doing anything [ __ ] grin
ronnie south smiling how come you're not
yet there he goes
there he goes come on gary pour it on
sal's laughing with a big grin
and yourself all the time i'm enjoying
it
i'm used to it i'm enjoying ronnie you
sound like an idiot
that's funny not to pile on but uh chris
is upset that ronnie took the package
from
someone more capable like himself like
he wanted to be in on this bit
you know we pitch ideas for packages
like this and we vie for them and we
rehearse them and
have a guy kind of come on and just bump
her through it
air time chris it's okay no i get air
time
you don't belong on the air here right
now that's the whole thing you don't
belong on the air you can't [ __ ] read
what was put in there why are you long
on the air bro 90 days ago
i believe on the air because you're a
disaster
you're a disaster more than you you're a
disaster
all right this is getting crazy i just
don't understand what's going on
sorry i'm not as big a star as you today
i understand that i didn't have a
billboard in vegas
you're supposed to be a writer i didn't
host
you're supposed to be a [ __ ] limo
driver you idiot
don't start that [ __ ] argument
i say from now on i'm making an edict
because i'm
the boss from now on ronnie delivers all
packages
all right everything he's the only one